we were literally just getting through
our to our everyday going with the flow
of what we need to do Harry was always
one thought for what he thought was
right we're honoring him by doing this
we just have to keep going to try and
get some closure all we need to do is to
meet her all we need to do is ask her to
come back it's not much to ask she's
left to family and complete ruin we're
broken inside and out many of us not
just direct parents but the siblings the
grandparents aunties uncles nieces it's
just everything we're all broken and we
just utterly shocked and appalled that
somebody is allowed to get on a plane
and go home and avoid our justice system
Tim do you understand the point of
diplomatic immunity I mean this phrase
you know must haunt you at the moment
but diplomats do need protection can you
understand it in this case we've looked
into this and our understanding was that
the immunity for the diplomat was to
keep them safe so that's why they have
immunity if they are under threat not
for something like this where they've
hurt somebody I don't see why that's how
that can be
how they can hurt somebody then just
leave doesn't make sense to me what
would you say tit and so coolest if she
were to see this injury Sky News have
tried to contact her but she's gone to
the United States and we can't find her
she's not returned to her home address
just to come home come back to us come
back to come back to the UK and we're
not we're not horrible family
we're a usual UK family that just need
to put a face to what we have now as a
name then talk to her find out how she's
feeling she's got to be suffering as
well you know she's a mom
without knowing who this person is
properly we can't begin to try and begin
to start out grieving process it's
interesting that you say that because
you're handling this with such grace and
dignity and bravery and what you want
from answer Kunis is answers not
necessarily not necessarily punishment
no not necessarily punishment at all we
just don't understand from one human to
another and one mum to another how you
could just get on a plane and leave
behind the devastation that she has
without even speaking to us or facing us
or an apology of any kind